Sebastian Lege zeigt euch, wie
Hackfleisch mit Hilfe von chemischen
Gasen länger frisch bleibt und testet,
welche Auswirkungen das auf den
Geschmack hat.
Für das Experiment hat Produktentwickler Lege seine Werkstatt in eine
möglichst keimfreie Umgebung verwandelt,
denn Bakterien aus der Luft sind der
Hauptgrund, warum frisches Hackfleisch so
schnell verdirbt.
Was für eine schöne, keimfreie Atmosphäre.
Aber um Hackfleisch lange hübsch und
frisch zu halten, reicht das noch lange
nicht aus. Dafür brauchen wir noch
richtig viel Gas.
Schutzgas lautet das Zauberwort. Die
Spezialmischung aus Sauerstoff und
Kohlendioxid schützt Hackfleisch vor dem
grau werden und dem Verderben. Wie in der
Industrie entfernt Sebastian erst einmal
mit einem Vakuumiergerät die normale
Luft aus der Verpackung.
Schon jetzt wäre das Hackfleisch länger
haltbar, doch seine rosa Farbe würde
rasch verblassen. Deshalb dreht Sebastian
gleich am Gashahn.
Jetzt kommt das passende
Mischungsverhältnis aus Sauerstoff und
Kohlendioxid.
Beide Gase kommen auch in normaler
Atemluft vor, nur im falschen
Mischverhältnis. Los geht's mit dem
Kohlendioxid. Langsam aufziehen, so. Jetzt - aufpassen.
Vorsichtig bläst Sebastian das Gas ein,
bis die Verpackung zu rund 30 Prozent
mit Kohlendioxid gefüllt ist. Das bremst
den Alterungsprozess des Fleisches.
Kohlendioxid hätten wir schon mal, jetzt
kommt Sauerstoff. Hmm, frischer Sauerstoff, herrlich.
Die Wunderwaffe für eine frische Farbe, denn eine spezielle
Substanz im Muskelfleisch bindet den
Sauerstoff, das Hack wird schön rot. 70
Prozent Sauerstoffgas sind dafür
optimal.
Fertig ist unsere Schutzgas-Atmosphäre.
Das Hackfleisch ist jetzt im
Kühlschrank rund fünf Tage haltbar.
Wie wichtig eine intakte Packung auch für
die Optik ist, zeigt dieser Zeitraffer.
Beide Packungen wurden mit Schutzgas befüllt,
doch die Linke ist undicht. Weil dort der
Sauerstoff entweicht, wird das Fleisch
grau, das rechts in der perfekten Schutz-
atmosphäre bleibt dagegen sogar über das
Haltbarkeitsdatum hinaus rosarot.
Doch wirkt sich die Schutzgas-Verpackung auf
den Geschmack aus?
Das lassen wir im Labor testen. Frisch
gekauftes Hack gegen vier Tage altes
Verpacktes.
Beide Proben werden bei exakt gleicher
Temperatur gegart.
Dann folgt eine Verkostung nach genauen
wissenschaftlichen Standards,
dazu zählt auch, dass keiner der
Testpersonen weiß, welches Produkt sie
isst.
Die geschulten Sensorikerinnen bewerten
alle Qualitätskriterien der Hackfleischproben.
In unserem Fall sind das: Zartheit,
Saftigkeit und Aroma.
In jeder Kategorie werden Punkte
vergeben, als Gesamtnote sind maximal
sechs Punkte zu erreichen.
Das Resultat: Nur 3,5 Punkte für das
abgepackte Hackfleisch, das Frische
bringt es auf 4,5. Doch - warum ist das so?
Das kann nur eine chemische Analyse
klären.
Wieder vergleichen wir vor vier Tagen
eingeschweißtes mit frischem Hack.
Hat der hohe Sauerstoffgehalt in der
Packung das Fleisch verändert? Dann würde
die Testflüssigkeit rosa.
Und tatsächlich: Die Färbung zeigt an,
das Fleisch aus der Verpackung ist
oxidiert. Der Fettanteil schmeckt dadurch
leicht ranzig.
Wenn ich natürlich ein schlechteres
Aroma und einen ranzigen Geschmack in
meinem Hackfleisch habe, habe ich
natürlich eine deutlich schlechtere
Qualität, was Geschmack und Genuss angeht
und somit kann Schutzgas dazu beitragen,
dass das Produkt qualitativ schlechter
ist. Ein Dilemma für die Hersteller, soll
das Fleisch gut aussehen oder gut
schmecken?
Der Sauerstoffgehalt im Gasgemisch
entscheidet, die Verbraucher erkennen nur,
dass die Ware mit Schutzgas verpackt ist,
nicht jedoch wie hoch der
Sauerstoffanteil darin ist.
Wir haben bei fünf Produkten den
Sauerstoffgehalt messen lassen.
Gemischtes Hackfleisch der vier
bekanntesten Handelsketten.
Auffällig: Der Sauerstoffgehalt ist in allen
Verpackungen unterschiedlich.
Und es gibt zwei Spitzenreiter: Das
Produkt von Rewe mit über 60 Prozent
Sauerstoff und das Bio-Hackfleisch von
Lidl, 70 Prozent Sauerstoff in der
Schutzatmosphäre. Gut für den Verkauf,
schlecht für den Genuss. Deshalb gilt:
Auch abgepacktes Hackfleisch besser
schnell verzehren.
Optisch immer noch rosa und wunderschön,
aber geschmacklich leidet ganz schön die
Qualität darunter. Schutzgas ist ein
nützlicher Hygienetrick und weil auch
die Hersteller die Nebenwirkungen von
Sauerstoff kennen, wird er fast
ausschließlich bei Produkten mit rotem
Fleisch eingesetzt.
Denn nur hier entsteht der gewünschte
optische Effekt.
Worauf achtet ihr beim Kauf von Hackfleisch und wie lange
bewahrt es auf? Sagt es uns in den
Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer Essen
wissen wollt, dann abonniert die ZDFbesseresser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei Clips.